welcome to everybody it's great great to
see you all here this is
handle on on the possibility of an
article five convention and of course I
don't need to tell this audience that
we've got a lot of problems very serious
problems in this country out-of-control
spending endless debt an entitlement
regime on an unsustainable trajectory
the rise in the in the growth of of the
administrative or bureaucratic state
wrapping us all in regulations and
administrative rules we have a judiciary
that legislates all the time and
increasingly so and to that we can now
add an executive that prefers not to be
bound by the rule of law so what do we
do about this does the Constitution
offer us a way out of the situation well
of course it does but what part of it
our panelists this morning are going to
debate which part of the Constitution
might be best to employ one option I've
gotten a lot of steam lately which seems
still unusual to many of us is for us to
hold a convention would be a convention
for proposing amendments under Article
five of the United States Constitution
the only way to save our country we're
told is to amend the Constitution and
the only amendment that can do so is a
balanced budget amendment and the only
way to get that is through an article v
convention and there are plans to do
this the second option is one that is
much more common one we're much more
used to though perhaps we don't use it
as effectively as we might and that is
politics that is to say the
constitutional process of citizens
governing themselves by electing rulers
who actually represent their views which
of these is best in our circumstances
what does prudence dictate to debate
that
have Michael Ferris and Larry yarn and
it's my pleasure to introduce both of
them I'll give their introduction here
for both of them at the start and then
call them each to the podium Michael
Ferris as Chancellor of Patrick Henry
College he is also chairman of the home
school Legal Defense Association and he
was in fact the founding president of
each of those organizations he's a
constitutional appellate litigator who
has served as lead counsel in the United
States Supreme Court in the eight
federal circuit courts and the appellate
courts of 13 States he's been a leader
on Capitol Hill for over 30 years and is
widely known for his leadership on
homeschooling religious freedom and the
preservation of American sovereignty and
at Patrick Henry College mr. Ferris
teaches constitutional law public
international law and coaches Patrick
Henry's food court team which is won
eight national championships a prolific
author mr. Ferris has been recognized
with a number of awards including the
Salvatori Prize for American citizenship
by the Heritage Foundation mr. Ferris
and his wife Vicki have 10 children and
17 grandchildren dr. Larry Arne is the
12th president of Hillsdale College he
received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD from the
Claremont Graduate School he served as
director of research for Sir Martin
Gilbert who's the official biographer of
Winston Churchill and from 1985 to 2000
he served as president of the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
and political philosophy in 1996 he was
the founding chairman of the California
Civil Rights initiative prop 209 which
was passed by California voters and
prohibited racial preferences in state
hiring contracting and admissions dr.
honors on the board of trustees at the
Heritage Foundation the Henry Salvatori
center of Claremont McKenna College the
Philadelphia society the intercollegiate
Studies Institute and the Claremont
Institute he's also published
widely in national newspapers magazines
periodicals and is also the author of
several books including Liberty and
learning the evolution of American
education and the founders key the
divine and natural connection between
the Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it he is also a
professor of politics in history
at Hillsdale and teaches courses on
Aristotle on Winston Churchill and on
the American Constitution and he and his
wife penny have four children I always
like getting to the last part of these
introductions where the children are
mentioned between the three men you'll
see up on stage there are 22 children
this morning I counted so if we can't it
might be a better way to beat the left
is to out populate them but in any event
without without further ado let me first
welcome Michael Ferris to the podium
well I want to note that you I did the
math you have eight children I think
that's a wonderful start that's great
is my honor and privilege to be here
this morning and to be invited to be a
part of this discussion today I would
like to just make one clarification the
proposal that I'm a part of for a
convention of the state's project is not
limited to a balanced budget amendment
there are there is a group that's
pushing that the project that I'm
involved with is seeking an article five
convention for the three purposes to
impose fiscal restraints on the federal
government to limit the power and
jurisdiction of the federal government
and imposed term limits on federal
officials that would be both members of
Congress and the judiciary
and so in short our goal is to limit the
power of Washington DC so I start with
the proposition that functionally in
this country there are two constitutions
there's the Constitution as written by
the founders and then there's the
Constitution as interpreted by the
Supreme Court now once in a while those
things are the same very infrequently
are those the same the courts to most
readings recent decisions on the Second
Amendment are really pretty close to the
founders intent on those questions and
we got robust protection the key
question was are the second Amendment
rights and individual liberty or are
they group right only owned by the
militia and the court got that one
correct but that's the rare exception
the vast majority of cases that my
students study at the Supreme Court
level don't there's no coincidence
between the Supreme Court's decisions
and the original meaning of the
Constitution let's take one example the
Obama care decision Justice Roberts said
it was not an innovation on this part in
this particular decision but he said
that the general welfare Clause imposes
no subject matter limitations on the
power of Congress to tax and spend
I don't want to live in a country where
there's no constitutional limitation on
the power of the federal government to
tax and spend now there was a debate
between the founders on this there was a
view Hamilton had one view and Madison
had another view but it's not the view
that it's commonly thought Madison's
view was the general welfare clause
which is the source of the trouble here
did not grant any additional power to
Congress at all whereas Hamilton had the
view that's improperly understood
Hamilton's view was actually the federal
government got power provided two things
one it was truly in the national
interest rather than some local interest
and secondly that it was beyond the
jurisdiction the subject matter
jurisdiction of the states to spend
money on that topic simply put if the
states can spend money on it then the
federal government cannot spend money on
that topic under either of the founders
views and all the problems that we have
in this country on spending would be
fixed by either Madison's view or
Hamilton's view I'll take either one
today thank you very much but the
Supreme Court gives us something quite
different we have a president who's
already been alluded to by who says if
Congress won't do what I want them to do
I have a pen and I have a phone and I'll
basically I'll by executive Fiat make
the law that I want it to be and I don't
know what the phone is for I get the pen
unless he's getting orders from somebody
on what to do I you know I I'm curious
about the phone part article 1 section 1
of the Constitution says all legislative
authority is vested in the Congress of
the United States meaning only Congress
can make law we all my contention is the
Code of Federal Regulations 200 volumes
of it is unconstitutional because only
Congress can make law I contend that all
executive orders that bind private
people and private property is
unconstitutional the only Congress can
make law by the way the most important
rule in any organization is who has the
power to make law who has the power to
make the rules whether that's the
student council at Patrick Henry College
the women's ministry at the church or
the NFL or the government of the United
States who can make the rule
article 1 section 1 set that out for us
only the elected legislators of the
people can make the rules
number 3 approximately 30 times the
Supreme Court the United States has said
the only effective checks on our power
is the courts own sense of
self-restraint
I don't want to live in a country where
there's no better check and balance on
the Supreme Court than that now the
results of this have already been
mentioned and we all know them but I'll
just give you a little detail the Center
for Public Integrity not a conservative
organization Arianna Huffington's on the
board the Center for Public Integrity
says that in 2020 89% of the federal
income will be devoted to just four
things interest on the national debt
Medicare Medicaid Social Security that's
it
11 percent will be dedicated to
everything else including national
defense it's an impossible situation the
country will fail we see the government
spying on our soin citizens we see
religious freedom being forced to give
way to homosexual rights we see
international treaties being used to
control the domestic policy in the
United States in an increasing fashion I
submit this proposition I don't care who
we send to Washington DC Washington DC
will never limit its own power ever and
the founders believe that as well and
they gave us a solution particularly
George Mason gave us a solution the
proposal on the table at that moment in
the Constitutional Convention was to
have Congress propose all constitutional
amendments they knew too that we would
need constitutional amendments they knew
that structure was important to the
preservation of freedom and they knew
that if something got a little a ride
that you need to have the opportunity to
make structural changes that experience
would show were necessary and so the
proposal was Congress proposed all
amendments the state ratify all the
amendments and that seemed balanced
except for Mason said this if you want
any amendments they're going to limit
the power of Washington DC they can
never be originated in that
you have to give the states the ability
to unilaterally propose amendments and
ratify amendments the states are the
parents after all the states should have
the power to unilaterally change the
structure of Washington DC's power to
rein it in if it gets out of bounds
that's why they wrote article 5 the way
they did
I think it's self-evident that we need
structural change to protect Liberty so
why wouldn't we do this there's only two
reasons that are offered at least by
conservatives one is the plan that's
been alluded to already there's a better
plan that's more feasible if we elect
better people we like more conservatives
more principled people to office then it
will be better in 1999 I organized two
events regarding presidential candidates
one was a rally for homeschoolers and we
had though held out a Constitution Hall
later the same day there was an
interview by social conservative leaders
with presidential candidates
I rode from Constitution Hall in the
back of a SUV with then gore
Governor George W Bush to the
presidential interviews at the interview
then Governor Bush said I was asked the
question rather are you going to try to
abolish the federal Department of
Education and he said Ronald Reagan
promised the two duvall abolish the
federal Department of Education and he
was unable to do so I don't want to make
promises that I'm unable to keep I don't
think that there's any ability to get
such a proposal through Congress and I'm
not going to make a promise to the
people that I don't think is realistic
to keep it was an accurate honest
assessment he wanted to but instead we
ended up with No Child Left Behind and
so
electing better people you all know this
the definition of insanity is try to do
the same thing over and over again hope
for better results I've been involved in
the political process for a long time I
have no illusions that Washington DC
will be any better Washington DC elects
conservatives that are sent here more
than conservatives affect Washington DC
that's just a truth and you can take
that to the bank the second reason that
people proffer that we should not pursue
a convention the states under article 5
is the danger of a run a supposed
runaway convention they contend after
all wasn't the Constitution itself the
result of a runaway convention and an
illegal act the states were told just to
amend the Articles of Confederation and
instead we ended up with a whole new
document unfortunately people have been
believing that for a long time because
you got their history from the common
core and its precursors it is not true
that is defamation against the founders
and defamation against the Constitution
itself and it presupposes that Congress
had power that a it didn't use and B it
never had so let me explain it to you
let me under Avila the Annapolis
convention was held in Annapolis
Maryland not that far from here five
states participated curiously Maryland
wasn't one of them
makes sense and so the Annapolis
Convention was called by Virginia to
consider changes relative to commerce
they got together and they said hey we
don't have enough states here B we don't
have enough authority to discuss the
range of issues that we need to discuss
so they made a compact between
themselves to go back to their states
and ask their states for authority to
call a convention in May to discuss how
to and I quote render the Federal
Constitution adequate for the exigencies
of the Union they said we will notify
Congress out of courtesy but Congress
doesn't have any authority to call such
a convention under Article under the
Articles of Confederation so Congress
was notified but not asked Virginia and
New Jersey on the same day called the
Constitutional Convention twelve other
states
pointed delegates and gave them their
authority to act 10 of the states used
the exact wording of the article of the
Annapolis convention resolution the
delegates were told their task was to
render the Federal Constitution adequate
for the exigencies of the Union
Massachusetts in New York said that plus
only amend the Articles in Federalist 40
Madison explains why he believes that
both sets of delegates correctly
performed their duties but the question
about the runaway is limited to the
delegates of New York and Massachusetts
the other 10 states did exactly what
they were supposed to do with no
legitimate question whatsoever so what
did Congress do Congress in February of
1787 endorsed the convention it said
Congress is the opinion that would be
expedient for the convention to be held
seven states had already called the
convention named their delegates and
given them their instruction when that
happened the idea that Congress called
the convention that Congress told them
to only amend the Articles and they did
not obey Congress is historically false
and nonsense Congress had no such power
the states called the convention under
the residual sovereignty which they
still possessed today they could call a
constitutional convention it would be
outside of article 5 any state that
didn't want to participate wouldn't have
to in the the work product the states
wouldn't have to participate just like
they didn't have to participate when the
Constitution was adopted Rhode Island
and in North Carolina set it out for a
while they didn't join under that
because they they wanted the Bill of
Rights at least North Carolina did I'm
an ordained Baptist pastor also I can
criticize Baptist you if you're not you
can't but what I was just being Baptist
state they just were being separate and
they didn't you know they were contrary
three states last year passed our
resolution for our articles excuse me
for a convention the states under
article 5 Georgia Florida Alaska we got
it through the house in Alaska in
Alabama skinny in Arizona and Alabama
we're gonna fix that and get it all the
way through this year our goal is 20
States I need your help I need people
who believe that we should be governed
under the Constitution as written
the only way to effectively correct the
Supreme Court is to amend the
Constitution to say the general welfare
Clause does not mean you can tax and
spend for any fool thing you want and a
few other things like that we get those
things right American freedom can
flourish thank you very much
thank you Mike that was good
so I grew up in the south as did Mike
and I went to the Church of Christ which
thought the Baptist led a turret
latitudinarian so I'm able to tell
Baptists jokes and do you know why
Baptist don't like premarital sex might
lead to dancing so I have a few points
to make about this the Constitution is
made to be amendable it had to be
it couldn't be amendable by the ordinary
processes of government and the reason
is it's the only law that the people
ever made the Constitution was not made
by the states it was made by the people
in the states and states don't have
rights they have authorities people have
rights in the founding literature they
do sometimes say that states have rights
but they mean rights in the sense of
authorities that is things granted to
them by people who are sovereign
creatures of God never to be governed
except by their consent so in the
mending process because this is the only
law that was ever passed by the people
as as I say organized in their states
but by a process outside the state
governments this process created
especially for the purpose of
ratification conventions for it to which
people were elected by the people a
process that passed away once it was
used so how are you going to amend it it
has to be amendable because it has to
remain in some important sense in the in
the hands of the people and problems
have to be fixed and that has to be some
extraordinary process that commands a
supermajority and so an article 5 they
provide the two ways it's a big thing to
amend this constitution because although
it's got plenty of flaws
it's the best thing of its kind ever buy
a lot it's not just the oldest living
written constitution it's the only thing
of its kind that ever lasted a long time
when Barack Obama took the oath of
office he took the same oath that George
Washington took and when he turned and
gave the little speech his was too long
after his after his inauguration it's at
the same level of abstraction and the
same kind of thing as all of the others
that it wouldn't be given that had been
given it's a long continuous
constitutional history Ronald Reagan's
first inaugural which I regard as one of
the best ever given and some really
beautiful ones have been given Lincoln
of course and George Washington among
them people who had a deep understanding
of the Union I think in modern times in
1981 Ronald Reagan gave a inauguration
address that is one of the finest a sign
of the continuous constitutional history
and so the Constitution was made to be
amendable and not easily amendable there
are 27 amendments to the Constitution
none of them have been passed by this
method and and there's a reason for that
I think I think first of all it's hard
to amend the Constitution and this
process has not proved ready in the past
this article 5 process I mean I don't
mean the constant the conventions that
were called before the Constitution was
passed the Constitution being the
supreme law of the land and I don't mean
even the 1861 Washington peace
convention where they tried to gin up
some of them in minutes to stop the
Civil War from breaking out
these 27 amendments have something in
common they fall into two groups and
only two I think many of them are
technical they fix a problem this or
that presidential succession term limits
for the president things like that and
then some of them are fundamental the
Bill of Rights the 13th 14th and 15th
Civil War amendments the direct election
of senators and those amendments never
came is the solution to a raging
controversy they memorialized the
victory the Civil War amendments were
passed after the Civil War and if the
plan had been in 1854 in that time that
I told you about introducing this
conference if the plan had been in 1854
to propose a bunch of amendments of the
Constitution and of course it would have
gone nowhere because the country was
deeply divided and so usually it's a
weak idea to think we're going to fix
all this by getting together and
changing the Constitution the processes
is as mr. Ferris describes it is in fact
constitutional and good for him he's
trying to do something as she always
does my main point is not that I oppose
this although I think I do but I think
that there's a lot of questions here and
I think that they would need to be
answered first the kinds of amendments
that are proposed there are two main
groups right now and one of them
proposes a single shot and thing it's
page and a half long there's a and what
it would do is require that the dead of
the United States not rise above a
certain level and the taxes not rise
there's a companion to that that would
require that 2/3 or 3/4 of the states
would pass a compact with one another
before the convention method the
convention wouldn't do anything else
except
past this one thing and all of the
delegates would go committed by their
states to do this and all the states
would be committed to one another and
that kind of thing it seems to me
probably sends a better chance of
passing and being well-written than a
general set of amendments and on the
other hand there problems with that that
would require some more thinking before
one favored that is it stands right now
I do not favor it and the reason is
there's a word that's missing from the
draft that goes about and that word is
war most important power that's given to
the federal government is war and in the
Second World War for example I think we
were spending somewhere approximately
70% of the gross domestic product of the
country on the war effort and you can
say that that war was a bad idea if you
want to but that war actually started
when Japan attacked the sovereign
territory and the military of the United
States at Pearl Harbor and then a few
days later Nazi Germany declared war on
us wasn't clear that we were going to
declare war on them and so you're going
to defend yourself
that's what it took at the end of the
Second World War we had 27 carrier
groups and and it would have been no
victory over Japan no retaliation for
the attack on the American military
without those and those things were
expensive because there were millions of
men building and supporting and and
women and and operating those those
ships and planes and many died and they
need the support and in the article 1
section 8 of the Constitution about half
of it of the grants that are given to
Congress are War Powers so what this
thing would do is it would say that that
if there's a war then you can't raise
the debt unless 26 state legislators
vote and pass a resolution saying it so
and it adds another step and you know
executive action and war they have their
own time line you can say and speculate
if you want that that they would all be
for it if there was something like an
attack on
Harbor but circumstances have a way of
working out the way they work out and I
don't know if he read the newspapers but
there are signs of war everywhere and
since Pearl Harbor the worst attack on
the soil of the United States by foreign
enemies was on September 11 2001 not so
very long ago
so you didn't so that's a detail right
and turns out it's an important detail
and in order to get this kind of thing
done what you've got to do if it's gonna
be the narrow Condit's you've got to get
an agreement you've got to say we can
all go with this thing right we're going
to limit the power of the federal
government to borrow and to spend that's
an indirect way of going at the problem
because the heart of the problem is not
really even in the borrowing and
spending there's a reason behind the
borrowing and spending and that is a
different view of what government is for
and a different view of how human beings
are to live and what kind of thing they
are and so we vote for these programs
one after another after another and and
and you know the ability to vote for
them declines as time goes on because
the government does indeed become a
force of its own including in the
electoral process but it is fueled and
has its energy from different purposes
and the end of there's going to have to
have to be those are going to have to be
addressed and the star of the beast
method only addresses it indirectly and
it'll be hard to do it takes thirty
three or four states I think they're
twenty eight or nine states right now
that are in Republican hands Arkansas is
one of them I think they lately
rescinded one of their calls for a
convention these calls are common by the
way they've of times one state or
another a group of states is called for
a convention and has never gone all the
way to the end and so the narrow way
still faces enormous income
and the wider way which is what I
understand mr. Ferris supports but which
is proposed by my friend and a very
learned man Mark Levin who has 11 or 12
amendments that he proposes and they're
good he's you know very knowing guy and
you know there's one of those I don't
like but but if you could pass all of
those in fact I think nearly all of
those should be passed in legislation
which may be impossible to do but it's
hard to admit it but it's it it's harder
to call a convention and get all those
things past because they amount to a
restructuring of the Constitution the
United States they include things like
nullification by state so if two-thirds
of the states I think he says in his
proposal were to not like a federal law
than they could nullify it you know
James Madison himself is on record about
that idea when it was proposed by John C
Calhoun and it so so in that case a
convention is going to meet if you can
get it called with this purpose in mind
it's going to meet and propose
far-reaching changes to the Constitution
the United States and I myself I'm not
as worried about a runaway convention as
I am about an idiot convention because
the idiot quotient is very high today
and the people who met you know you know
mr. Ferris and I don't agree 100% on
this but it's not going to be him and me
right
that's not who's going to show up at
this convention it's gonna be the
appointees of if they all go 50 state
legislatures and who they gonna find you
know the Blessed legislature of
Massachusetts in its wisdom who they
gonna send right they gotta send
Elizabeth Warren
I understand that George Soros is
interested in this process thinks it
offers a lot of opportunity I understand
that there's a revival of the Equal
Rights Amendment except it'll be
different this time because you know
there aren't just two genders anymore
and the claims that are made now in
Maryland it's the law that anybody has a
right to go to whichever put any public
bathroom into which they are inclined on
that day if this thing we're going to be
important and if it got steamed and and
it may although such a thing never has
although often debated and rallied
around if it gets steamed and it's going
to be opposed and it's going to be
artfully opposed and there's gonna be
campaigns about who gets to go like
Massachusetts a great person to go would
be Elizabeth Warren she would love to
rewrite the Constitution the United
States and what would it look like when
she did have you read the year what's
Constitution making like these days
goodness sakes when the when the
government of the United States gives
advice to countries about what kind of
Constitution they should write it reads
like the constitution of the European
Union which was never passed but anyway
was implemented anyway
no no constituency in your preserver
voted for that thing but they do it
anyway now while we engage in all of
this what we're going to be doing is
committing ourselves to changing the
constitution our argument will be to
restore it that's I'm confident
genuinely what mr. Ferris proposes but
it isn't right now it's been distorted
we have to put it back it's not adequate
to our purposes as it stands and so then
there'll be another group and they will
say Amen that's exactly right and so
what happens when two large power
forces come together to support
something right if they do anything at
all they do some compromise and how do
those compromises tend to go today and
so then you can like for example what if
you wrote like there's a thing that I
favor very much is a piece of ordinary
legislation and if you had both houses
of Congress and the president ins you
could pass it and you know it's a it's
not unimaginable in fact it's plausible
that you could get somebody elected
president in 2016 who would sign this
thing called the reins Act one of the
candidates is likely to be a fellow who
did something very like it in his state
lately in the face of demonstrations and
shutdowns and every kind of thing the
legislature escaped from the state for a
while because RJ said at the beginning
of this what our problems are and
they're only two one can name them
there's an entitlement state that is out
of all bounds and there's a regulatory
state that is lawless and now the
popular branches are becoming less
lawful but in that odd though because if
we start out what's the claim that the
Constitution United States is really
good but they're not following it so
let's amend it now and then they will
they might not they don't this one so my
inclination is to say this just knowing
the history a little bit I don't have
the honor of being a lawyer I almost did
though I decided to get an education
sorry I like mr. fair so I felt entitled
to make that joke my inclination would
be to say this mindful of the way that
these things have unfolded in the fan
past mindful the fact that neither
Washington nor the state capitals or the
state governments are monolithic uniform
edifices there's a lot of things that
are going on in Washington right now
that are better than they used to be
there are several people who sit on the
Supreme Court who are among the best who
ever sat there there's one in particular
who is the best one of the best anyway
and there's a different spirit in the
House of Representatives
I know it's pitiful but on the range of
you know pitiful to simply tyrannical
it's way over here toward pitiful now
which is likely the way by the way a
constitutional convention would be if it
was very successful it might be up there
like pitiful whereas the people who
wrote the Constitution United States
think of the agreements that they had
that everyone had you can't find any
serious founder who didn't think human
slavery was an evil even among the
slaveholders you can't think you can't
find anybody in the American Revolution
who don't think that the didn't who
didn't think that the Declaration of
Independence is the simple statement of
the case you can't find anybody among
the Federalists and the anti-federalists
they all agreed the rhetorical position
of the anti-federalists is the central
government has got to get stronger
because we're not able to defend
ourselves and pay our debts and it's an
edge pitiful the Great Britain keeps
forts on our soil having lately sworn
they wouldn't do it anymore because we
don't have any means to stop them right
they there there is nobody who doesn't
think that power has to be divided
among branches and up and down between
the states and the federal government
there's nobody who doesn't think that
the people are sovereign and they must
never be governed except by their
consent there's nobody who doesn't think
that every human being
facing necessity has to have as to have
property to live and his life is spent
in the work of getting the property
Lincoln said about slavery after this
consensus had begun to break down as it
has broken down again in our time he
said God made every man with one hand
and one head in one mouth and two hands
and the implication was the head was the
guide the hands and the feeding of the
mouth and in the time of the American
Revolution everybody believed that and
where are we today today that is hotly
contested and the population breaks down
into three groups intellectuals who are
likely actively and on and on the basis
of long thought to disbelieve those
things and then a lot of people in the
middle who are ignorant of it and then
me and Mike and you so here's what I
think I think that events is a mr.
Ferris has written I think that events
are likely to make us better I think
we're even getting better and I'm
hopeful about the future although you're
never in a fundamental battle that it
doesn't look dangerous because it is but
I think the way that we're going to get
better is that we're going to have a
fundamental fight about these things
that are being done in the government in
the entitlement state and you know
another thing look at the immigration
thing what that's about is simple is
just like something King George was
doing the government is actually
claiming the authority to define the
constituency that elects it and that's
what King George was up to right they
complained about it in the Declaration
of Independence he wanted to include
parts of candidate because they thought
that he thought that would support him
and so I think that we're going to
address these things in the ordinary
course
politics and then one of these days
we'll win and we'll get this under
control and then we'll pass some
amendments maybe thank you
well thank you both for those those
remarks and I think what we'll do before
we turn things over to the audience is
just very briefly if the speakers would
like to respond to one another just just
for a couple of minutes we'll do that
and then turn things over to the
audience Larry has raised a lot of
questions but there are answers to every
single one of them we raised and if you
understood the details of the process
most of these questions are easily
resolved let's take for example who will
be sent to the convention you know will
Massachusetts is Elizabeth Warren well
yeah
so what Virginia by the way I do plan to
be there
as the delegate from Virginia I have a
working relationship with the
legislature of Virginia and I'm planning
to keep working that relationship and I
do plan to be a delegate but the each
state legislature appoints its delegates
the key fact is it's one state one vote
and so let Massachusetts soon who are
they want there are 17 states that are
controlled by Democrats and there gets
17 votes it doesn't matter how many you
know famous liberals they send it's an
irrelevance II count the votes and if
you can count the votes you know you
really do need to understand the process
when 27 states are controlled by
Republicans in both houses and five
states are controlled by Republicans in
one house and Democrats in the other
house it is impossible to get a majority
vote without Republican votes being a
serious component part of it on crazy
things could be passed at the end of the
day 38 states have to ratify which means
simply that 30 single house and 13 state
votes no it gets voted down crazy things
are not going to happen liberals are not
going to take it over because it's not
like Washington DC where power and money
and influence are the controlling
factors it's the people the strength of
the conservative movement is not in
Washington DC for big cities big
government and big media control
all it's in the States and in the people
of the States it's our only opportunity
if we're going to leverage power
appropriately let's go where we have the
advantage we have the strategic
advantage in the States we do not have
it in Washington DC he raised a lot of
quote points about particular part
amendments like this one doesn't have
war power and the balanced budget
proposal and all of that he's trying to
prejudge the work of the convention
itself the convention has to write the
amendments it's not you're not writing
the text upfront the proposals that want
to do that they're not going to get
anywhere they're not there's no momentum
for those and they're probably a
violation of article 5 the courts have
held multiple times that when the state
legislators in Congress use article 5
power they are not using ordinary
legislative power you cannot use
ordinary legislative processes to
control article 5
article 5 controls article 5 the states
will send the delegates the delegates
will write the amendments the amendments
will have to be topical for the
applications the states call if it's
outside that it's it's improper and
there are lots of checks and balances to
stop improper amendments outside this
subject matter we don't have to get
worried about wording it correctly at
this stage the question before us today
is should we call a convention and would
it propose things the last thing they'll
say is this if they're not going to obey
it today why will they obey it later and
the answer is we've got to have checks
and balances on the court the reason we
don't obey it today is because of the
Supreme Court of the United States
that's the truth and if we're going to
have a government that obeys the
Constitution we've got to fix that and
so real checks and balances on the
Supreme Court if you read the Supreme
Court's writing carefully the thing that
they believe is the most great of the
gravest constitutional crisis in the
history of the Republic was the
roosevelt court packing scheme what
because it intruded on their power they
want power and they don't they are
perfectly content with having the the
situation where
there is no checks and balances under
the other than their own internal sense
of self-restraint ladies and gentlemen
we have the ability to call a convention
that would take would that would address
that problem and we can see if we like
the solution if L like the solution 38
states will ratify if we don't like the
solution we tried we didn't succeed I am
against sitting down and hoping for the
best when trying the same old stuff I'm
in favor of using the Constitution's own
process for the times that Mason said
would come when the government exceeded
its authority if we're not going to do
it now when will we ever do it
when a course of action is proposed the
way you decide whether to take it or not
is to prejudge that it's one wonder what
nor us do state capitals are not it's a
very different than Washington DC I was
in Austin Texas lately
big red state you want to know how they
regulate education just the same the No
Child Left Behind Act was born in Texas
they but lately carved out some latitude
but that's the exception to the rule and
you know of the bureaucracy in America
about two million people in at work in
Washington DC and about 21 million
people and at work in the states mostly
in the capitals the National Education
Association grew out of the Michigan
Education Association and I can tell you
it's not very friendly to go up to
Lansing Michigan the legislators are
good and pretty good at least in most of
those states but the thing is you can't
have both arguments right first of all
if there's a consensus in 38 states to
pass a bunch of really good stuff of
which a list has been made then why
doesn't it pass and elect enough people
in Congress to do that is it because
they all get corrupt when they get here
to Washington DC because by the way I
know a lot of them I don't think that's
true I think that I think the country is
divided about these things
I to them against sitting and hoping and
doing the same old thing American
politics like all free politics and to
the extent they're still free they
proceed by argument and debate I've had
kidded myself for a long time and you
can say okay he's advocated for a long
time and it hasn't worked but you know
there's progress and this crisis you
know how long did the slavery crisis
take it took from 1815 roughly until
1870 roughly something like that how
long did the American revolutions take
the friction started in 1763 and it
brought you could mark the ending of it
either in the implement implementation
of the Constitution in 1789 ninety or in
the election of the Jefferson government
the first time a free government ever
changed hands according to the will of
people in 1800 so first of all it's not
to pronounce that it has failed
just remember free government is like a
dog walking on its hind legs it's a
miracle it can happen at all and so I
repeat my point right I'm not afraid of
this my reservations are I don't think
it can be done if it is done I will do
what I can to help with it I don't have
the leisure that mr. Ferris seems to
have to hang out with the legislature of
Michigan and anyway I don't like them
very much but but but you know I might
get picked I know some of them and if I
get picked I'll go and I'll do my best
but I'm just saying right now really
we're gonna do better than they did when
in fact the text of the Constitution is
basically intact right now and so we are
going to spend our time and our energy
on this thing
about how it's so important to change it
because the people no don't think so
okay I think we will take some questions
from the audience I believe we have
folks roving with microphones so if you
would like to ants ask a question please
raise your hand and one of them will
make their way over to you okay in the
back yes sir hi good morning a Steve
Kline Hillsdale low-five Cheyenne
Wyoming I really appreciate your remarks
this morning and this question
particularly goes to mr. Farris but dr.
Arnn if he would comment as well because
we heard it at the beginning but then we
didn't seem to have a much detail in
regards to term limits what's the what's
the justification behind that it seems
to only go to dr. Ahn's comment that
eventually over time people become
corrupted but it's in my experience
especially at the state level that term
limits are probably one of the best
things to ever happen to the
administrative state that often
bureaucrats protected by many civil
service protections and the like can sit
in front of when a legislature is doing
something they don't like or not and
they're not or they're not implementing
the law is written that when someone's
coming after them all they really have
to do is wait and wait and eventually
those term limits kick in and a good
legislator who was going after a
particular Department is now on the way
out and the administrative state remains
and the same power it was in can you
hear me okay
I have two responses first of all one of
the amendments that I I would like to
see happen is the elimination of the
ability of the administrative state to
exist i when I was the chairman of the
governor's task force and regulatory
reform in Virginia I propose that all
regulations could by the administrative
agencies could only be proposed they had
to go to the legislature to actually be
passed and I think that that would have
to be the case as well at the federal
level we're true
follow article 1 section 1 that all law
should be passed so that we have
political responsibility for those who
are enacting the law so I want to take
away the power of this sural alleged
Ministry of agency employee that you've
described secondly the term limits issue
is principally a coalition building
state at this point in time it's these
are the topics for the discussion at the
convention personally I am far more
interested in term limits on the
judiciary that I am term limits on the
Congress because we have to seek some
checks and balances on the judiciary and
I think term limits on the federal
judiciary is one of the things that
should be discussed as an option it may
not be the the best solution at the end
of the day but to make it be available
for discussion you've got to include it
in the call and and so term limits are
very popular among people for members of
Congress my biggest concern about term
limits for members of Congress is that
if only some states do another state
stone it puts States at a disadvantage
if it's done uniformly across the
country then I'm more for it but but
that's not my biggest agenda my base
agendas fix the Commerce Clause fix the
general welfare clause do something to
balance the federal judiciary we fix
those things also get rid of the ability
to use international treaties to govern
the domestic policy in the United States
something that Tom Harkin tried to do
yesterday so you know you write the
amendments at the convention you set the
agenda what's on the table to talk about
all we're committing to today is term
loser worthy of discussion so Howie rich
who used to run us term limits used to
put on his newsletter every month
a chart and it showed propensity to
spend by congressmen overtime and there
was a line for the Democrats and the
line for the Republicans and he's a good
guy I know I'm and I one day I said to
him talking to him on the phone I said
have you ever noticed that over here on
the far end of the Republican line it's
lower than the beginning point of the
DIMM
pratik Buntline you know when they get
to be the worst spenders in the world
now they're ready to join the freshman
class of the Democratic Party except
sell a bit lower than that and I just
said you know I'm not pumping for the
Republican Party but the most powerful
explanatory factor about propensity to
spend on your own chart is party
affiliation matters who you elect what
about the Supreme Court I so yeah I
agree with Hamilton about that what I
think is like the Obamacare decision was
frightful in my opinion but on the other
hand the American people elected the
people who passed that darn thing and so
the courts are supposed to undo it and
the courts you know the googly argument
in the Federalist is that the courts
have they don't have a popular base
they're not as close to the sovereign
which in America used to be the people
and so they don't have the force and you
know the Congress can by the way by a
simple act of legislation limit the
appellate jurisdiction of the course
they've never done it but they could and
that's easier than then calling a
constitutional convention and and so and
you know my experience with term limits
I used to live in California is we
passed them I didn't like it and then of
course all of the really good ones they
got termed out and they were replaced by
mediocrities the bad ones because the
good ones are pretty rare and and so
they're in this day and age so they're
harder to replace so I've never thought
that's much of a solution and I do think
if there was a clear majority I think
the Supreme Court does it's most
controversial and difficult things when
the nation is divided and it finds its
opportunities for evil there and if it
gets United if it doesn't get United
we're going to lose it and if it does
get United then I got a feeling that
won't be as bad a problem as it has not
been for much of American history thank
you
yes sir hi I'm Dan McGinnis I'm from
Round Hill Virginia both you gentlemen
have talked about the illegal activities
of both sides of Congress and of of the
president I as part of the solution at
least on a micro-level
no one's talking about making the
Attorney General position an elected
position why is that i under our
application that would be a germane
recommendation and so changing the power
and jurisdiction of the federal
government is something that is is
that's the topic matter and so good
suggestions I think it's worthy of
discussion I know I don't think it would
get 26 states to vote for 238 states
ratified by by might be wrong but it's
worthy of discussion because the
question is are we going to have law
enforcement and enforcing the orders of
the government responsible to the
president or not or should there's be
some independence there that's worthy of
discussion and that's the kind of thing
we can either talk about it in a forum
where we just talk about it or we can
talk about it in a forum where this
where the people have the authority to
do something about it and the only forum
we have where the people have the
authority to do something about it is in
the convention of the states under
article 5 it's correctly not called an
Constitutional Convention that's a
planet polluted potentially I can't even
say that correctly I can spell it but it
is a general convention with you have
the authority to change the entire
government that cannot be done under
article 5 the only thing that can be
done under article 5 is proposed
amendments on particular topics whatever
the applications would be and and so
we're not going to have a constitutional
convention Virginia is the one who named
it when they passed the first
application under article 5 even before
the Constitution was operational and
they called it a convention the states
and that's what it's been called
throughout history properly so it's a
convention to propose amendments to do
exactly the same thing that that
Congress is being done so having an
attorney general be set from the
president's is worthy of thinking about
I'm not sure where we go are you gonna
be able to use your influence with the
Virginia legislature to get them to
issue a call because they didn't didn't
they fail to do so lately
yeah they last year listening to the
John Birch Society and other people
advancing nullification I mean they were
there lobbying they they did that and
and so we are you know if I can't get
Virginia to pass it then sure we're not
going to get to thirty-four states but
we have you know we're working on that
and we're out beating the grassroots by
the way the basic plan is this there are
40 states where we think this is
politically even theoretically possible
and there's ten states that are so
liberal
we're not even concerned about trying to
organize they're particularly in those
40 states there are 4,000 State House
districts 4,000 State House districts if
we can organize 75% of those districts
that's that's 3,000 districts a hundred
people in each of the House districts if
they will write and call contact their
state legislature urge them to adopt a
convention the state's application urge
them to ratify the amendments that is
our plan to put grassroots pressure a
hundred people x 75% of the district's x
4000 districts is three hundred thousand
people in this country that's not very
many that's 1/10 of 1% of the population
I've explained this plan to about 500
state legislators which is one third of
the total vote needed to pass a concept
to ratify a constitutional amendment tip
515 1500 votes nationwide and so all of
them have said without exception you
actually produce that level of
grassroots activism this will pass and
what will happen politically the process
that you're arguing for that we should
just do politics people are not doing
politics at the same level of enthusiasm
they as they were just a few years ago
because they don't think they can make a
real difference they elected people in
the Tea Party sweep urging them thinking
they were really going to change things
in Washington DC and Washington DC
overtook them the tea party people
weren't that you know strong once they
got here to Washington DC and people are
frustrated
this gives people real hope because it
is real this process is real it's
written in the Constitution it's not
something we're making up out of thin
air we're following the actual text of
the Constitution and when you give
people the belief that something really
can't be done it's like a
self-fulfilling prophecy I've had the
benefit of seeing God do miracles before
I was told like you alluded to earlier
the naa is so powerful you'll never get
homeschooling legalized anywhere in the
country that's what I was told in the
early 1980s well guess what
homeschooling is legal everywhere in the
country right now and I was there and
watched it happen day by day by day
small dedicated grassroots people
depending on God made it happen we
fought we won we beat not only the
teachers union but their normal
opponents which are they educate you
know the superintendent's Association
the State Department of Education we
beat them all because a small dedicated
people depending on God can still
perform the kind of activity in this
country that will work I believe it can
work as I've seen it and I've done it
before I tend to do it again
so I think you have to pick between
those two arguments either it's simple
and customary and it only takes 1,500 or
you need a miracle and and the point is
4000 congressional districts raising a
grassroots effort that's politics
that's what political parties do and and
you say and about the Tea Party here's a
brief history of recent America it turns
out politics turn on people so in 1981
Ronald Reagan was elected in 1980 and
took office in 1981 Ronald Reagan became
president United States and some
important things were changed there and
we got 25 years of less dangerous
government he didn't get the reform that
he needed all of it and he himself I
happen to know was disappointed in some
ways but goodness gracious didn't he do
a lot and he came within an inch of
picking Don Rumsfeld to be his vice
president and what we got instead since
Reagan is we've spent about nine billion
dollars running for president United
States and nobody has made the case in
the way that rate Reagan made it and so
don't underestimate the importance of
the fact that we are leaderless and in a
crisis you need leaders you really do
and so one of hopes that you're gonna
find some people like you know I like
Scott Walker for one I think the
governors myself a lot because they've
all done stuff and they're fighters some
of many of them are fighters and I'm not
trying to endorse anybody for president
right now but if you got somebody like
that elected president and he had these
ideas that you've got which are not just
your ideas a lot of people oppose them I
propose many I'm clear legislation
myself then all of a sudden the work
that's done in 4,000 congressional
districts doesn't actually have to try
to achieve something that is simply
unprecedented this has never been done
and it's been available to be done on
the ordinary processes of the
Constitution for more than 225 years so
again is it practical and and those are
my two abiding questions the first is
could you really do this with the
numbers that you got right because if it
really does get down to it where you're
gonna do something that will in fact
restructure the government of the United
States and do something to those
nineteen or twenty 1 million bureaucrats
that are working in state capitals
they're going to be organizing and all
of those congressional districts - and
they're going to be out spending you and
they're gonna they're gonna put people
up and all they've really got to do to
win is muddy the process it's just like
politics in other words whatever are the
disadvantages of doing the same old
thing as it is rhetorically called
they all apply here - and then the
second thing is those people from those
50 states are going to get together
and let's say they meet an Independence
Hall where the Declaration of
Independence was written and where the
Constitution was written and I'm just
arguing that those people will not be of
the quality of the people who gathered
there in 1776 and 1787 ok let's see we
get a couple more questions in I have to
wait for microphone I'm sorry yes sir my
name is Quinn Rikard I'm from
Lovettsville 14 so let's imagine that
this all does get past there is a
convention and the budget of the
balanced budget amendment is passed
what would implementation look like in
Washington and across the country
questions for both of you well I'm not
an advocate of a balanced budget
amendment standing alone I'm out I'm an
advocate of a balanced budget amendment
company by limitations on the federal
jurisdiction on spending I basically
think that federal jurisdiction on
spending ought to be subject matter
limited that the states have the
jurisdictional competence to spend money
on that topic the federal government
should not be able to spend money on
that topic at all if we follow that rule
the federal budget would be about 1
trillion dollars instead of about 3
trillion dollars and so that would be
about right and and so you know the
implementation on other areas dr. Arnn
proposed passing ordinary statute to
limit the appellate jurisdiction of the
Supreme Court here's the problem with
that if today we passed a limitation of
the appellate jurisdiction of the
Supreme Court on on abortion let's say
what that would do is freeze Roe versus
Wade in place the Supreme Court could
never reconsider Roe versus Wade all the
lower courts would be obliged to
continue to follow Roe versus Wade it's
not a good idea because you haven't
thought through the practical
implications of it if we would have done
that
the day before Roe vs. Wade was was
pronounced been a really good idea but
there wouldn't be the political need to
do it and so you've got to adopt
policies that make sense and you've got
to do things that will really work now I
would point out to dr. Arnn that what
he's doing today is exactly what he's
accusing the Democrats are doing just
throwing mud in the air just a little
this little that little the other thing
and if you if you evaluate his comments
seriously okay well I'll give you a list
but the there's not a real solution and
the and the process is a lot longer than
any other time carries you you said
because really this started when comrade
Roosevelt took over as president the
United States and so we we are getting
really close to being under a century of
government where the purpose of
government is to provide for our needs
rather than a government or the purpose
of government is to protect life liberty
and property and punish those who do
evil that's the difference between a
free country in a socialistic country
and it's been a long slide but the
people still basically believe in life
liberty and property and why we're not
why we're not doing the right things not
electing the right people well for one
thing they're not realistic plans and
they're not leaders to stand up and I
would just submit to you this
proposition not all leaders are running
for office sometimes leaders need to
stand up and be the
intellectual leaders who call for this
and Larry I would encourage you to use
your intellectual leadership to rather
than to ask questions and questions and
questions get in the fight and help us
actually do this your leadership would
be effective the number of people
joining our fight is increasing every
day and we are seeing very serious
people joining our effort on a continual
basis and I'd ask you to be one of them
stop asking questions and let's get you
know sitting on the sidelines let's get
into battle together I will be
microphone on I will be using my
intellect as my intellect in prayer is
guided and to assert first of all it is
not mud to say that this process has
been tried hundreds of times and never
been successfully completed that's a
fact
it is not mud to say that the consensus
about the nature of man and his rights
is worse today than the American
Founding that's a fact
it is not mud to say that the
understanding and operation of the
Constitution especially by the people
who know the most about it today is
worse than it was in the time of the
American Revolution that's a fact and to
call those things mud is mud okay I
think we're gonna I think we're gonna go
to the audience for to get a question in
I think that's best at the moment yes
ma'am oh hi jinny Thomas and I'm just
generally a troublemaker but I love
Hillsdale for putting this together this
is a better discussion than we have had
on this issue anywhere two things one is
Mike I think it would be valuable to
expose and explain and be transparent
about the coalition and the people and
the money that are behind this
grassroots initiative I think it's a
left-right coalition and that would be
valuable to show and secondly whether
maybe there's parenting issues that
could be brought in as dr. Proust rito
mentioned that you know if the problem
is with the kids do you use a text to to
form you know what's happening in the
family or is it a character human
quality anyway
the Jenny I'm not prepared I don't even
know the names of the people that are
the donors and nor would I ever
divulge this I think it's that would be
an improper request actually the but
I'll tell you I don't know a single
left-wing dollar that we've ever gotten
there's not this is not a left-right
coalition to get this through we're
going to have to convince some Democrat
states and Democrat legislators to vote
for us we're working right now for
example in West Virginia to encourage
Democrat legislators to see if you want
to save the coal industry the only way
to save the coal industries is to let
for West Virginia decide is coal policy
rather than Washington DC decided school
policy we're working with Democrat
legislators in Washington State to say
if you want to save Boeing jobs in
Washington State you've got to get the
EPA off Boeing's back and having
unrealistic mercury discharge rules so
yeah we were working with Democrat
legislators but to suggest that George
Soros or anybody else is behind this is
utter nonsense and I'll use that Larry
as an example of throwing well you you
said that George Soros was thinks this
is a good idea can I just finish well
well I will but it would be after I make
the judge just make okay up here quickly
okay the George our time to respond
George Soros has nothing to do with our
efforts he apparently thinks this is a
good idea he also thinks electing
senators is a good idea
he thinks electing a president is a good
idea article 5 is like using it's an or
it is a process of politics that's in
the Constitution
so as electing senators so is electing
president the fact let him go try if he
can get 34 states to apply a a
convention you know to pass applications
for purpose he wants let him do it I
don't think he can get it done but he
cannot hijack our application process
he's not involved and if that wasn't in
the interest of time I'm sorry
I do want to dr. Arnn because I never
said by the way there's a tape of this
thing I never said that George Soros is
behind your efforts I said I hear that
he's interested in them
and he has the latitude to get involved
and if he does he will muddy them up
well Larry I really I wish I wish I
could have said it differently I think
the my delusion I withdraw it I
apologize
what what I would but what I do think is
fair is you're raising a series of
questions you're throwing question after
question there and the format here today
doesn't allow me to systematically
answer your questions there are good
answers and I wish that we could have an
opportunity to sit with each other yeah
because I think I can answer to your own
satisfaction a lot of your questions and
if it's if we just have a bunch of
questions
we're throwing questions in the air but
for which there really are solutions
well my point is this we got to have a
real solution and I don't hear one
coming from you but I do apologize for
the mud farm yeah so we done you you
have you have the floor okay this is
your and then we have to conclude our
Jay is a Dean and that's almost like
demigod the man signs my paychecks so
yeah well I'll just make this last point
right I mean first of all if if this
were to happen which I don't predict
myself then you know I hope they put
Mike Farris there and you know I'd go
myself probably if I was asked although
I'm not dead certain of that and it and
sure it is by the way constitutional and
my point is really just simple this is a
large Prudential judgment about a bunch
of complicated things that have to
unfold in the future and I apologize but
that's the nature of the thing right
you're going to go to 4,000
congressional districts and you're going
to get 30 states to 230 eventually 38
to agree to something that changes all
of this and that'll be hard to do I said
so and then it's right to raise the
dangers and and there are many you're
correct to say but they boil down to two
and one of them is gracious sakes how
many times has has been tried and not
been successfully done and second and
you know the political majority in
America has changed three times and
through ordinary politics is what had
happened so that it's very slow to
change very very slow to turn it around
but it has been turned around in the
past and it always takes a long time and
the second thing is surely we can agree
that I mean you know you're really good
and I mean that sincerely are you James
Madison because you know I'm pretty good
too and I don't think I am okay and the
note that Larry Arne is not James
Madison no thank you very much to both
of our speakers for a very lively
exchange I believe we have a coffee
break for about 15 minutes and then we
look forward to the second session in
the morning thank you very much